all right so you heard about multiple myeloma now amyloidosis how many people here knows about
amyloidosis by itself like let's see because this is the knowledgeable group right but if you train
residents fellows internist there is a significant lack of knowledge what is amyloidosis is how you
diagnose them what is the initial workup is so the ash took an initiative 2023 where the panel
group members around 22 physicians actually come together and formulate this guideline it's a two
year plus work it includes neurologist hematologist cardiologist nephrologist patient advocates
and
what we see maybe other physicians are not seeing in the same way the neurologist think differently
um a cardiologist think differently so all whole group has to come together and make a guideline
it was a pretty impressive work and it takes a long time for us to make this diagnosis
so we are three domains that we worked on this guideline first was enhancing the clinical
suspicion diagnosis and organ
inflammation
and as you know as an hematologist we see the patient when the diagnosis either already happen
patient has a diagnosis and you're initiating the treatments but to educate internist and other
specialities that's what this guideline is all about and we actually work on that these are my
cois and this has already been published and there's a full detail article that can be read
um and we can see uh the evidence uh patient level evidence institution level evidence
randomized trials or single center studies the problem with amyloidosis is we have a very limited
literature published many publications we have is only one to two institutions so there's a lot of
key opinion driven answers rather than a true concrete data and that's what we are lacking
in this field so as you know about the multiple myeloma now you can see that what's the incidence
we are dealing with here 5.1 to 12 million per million cases only like it's pretty small number
of cases and where these patients go do you ever see these patients in the clinic or they die without
having a diagnosis that is the major problem with this disease even in the busy urban city the
average delay in the diagnosis is more than two years even the best of the best cardiologists can
miss this diagnosis not us or even i'm talking about cardiologists that's what happens and if
you catch this disease early you can make a big difference because we have quite amazing therapies
for these patients and especially our first line treatment is very tolerable treatments and you can
get 43 percent more than five years but you have to catch early treat early without the end organ damage
become permanent. So, as you know, the pathophysiology, it's similar to multiple
myeloma. It's kind of little difference only there is the protein misfolding and it deposits in the
heart, kidney, nerves, GI liver, and other organs. And key red flag symptoms are patient has monoclonal
hemopathy, but with significant fatigue. I mean, that patient has been watched like an MGUS for
10, 15 years before we starting to think there's something going on. MGUS with heart failure,
these patients have just been managed like a beta blocker, ACE inhibitors, and then later we find
out, oops, this is the amyloidosis. So, this is an unmet need that we diagnose these cases,
but we need a knowledge, we need awareness, we need other specialties to help us.
So, first is the red flag symptoms, and then you can enhance the suspicions,
diagnosis, and organ involvement. So, initially, we develop the PICO questions,
like, you know, what are the key questions we are answering here? So, a couple of questions
related to suspicion, then we have specific diagnosis and organ involvement. Then there is
a significant disagreement among the colleagues, because institutional practices vary, each
institution does differently. So, we have to all come up into the same level of understanding.
Now, initially,
the first couple of PICOs we were trying to answer is the cardiac symptoms. If we are suspecting the
cardiac amyloidosis, so the ASH recommends do all three testing, serum immunofixation,
urine immunofixation, and serum-free light chain assays. Now, here, a lot of, we figured it out
that in the communities, people are doing just SPAT without immunofixations. So, that's something to
be improved. So, use all three tests together for our first test, and then you can do all three tests.
First, PICO, like a suspected cardiac amyloidosis. Then the second question we are answering it,
let's say somebody has unexplained proteinuria. So, where, what we have to do in these cases?
Here again, we start with an screening, the light chains, electrophoresis pattern in the serum and
the urine. So, increase our suspicion for AL amyloidosis. Then we have monoclonal studies,
biomarkers, and non-diagnostic echo. Now, here, you need an ARC. You need a cardiologist who can
read an echo with the way the amyloidosis experts read. So, you need a GLS strain,
ventricular wall thickness, LVH. And in the ways, sometimes we can read the amyloidosis based on the
echocardiographic appearances, but sometimes we are not. But if we are really sure this is
concerning for amyloidosis, then you go for directly to the biopsy. But if the echo is equivocal,
then the things come up. Should we do the cardiac MR in these cases? But cardiac MR is not
available in all the community practices. So, that's why early referral to the larger centers,
it's very, it's an unmet need that people know about these things so that you can quickly
diagnose these cases. Then here, if we look at it, the algorithms, so what happens that if these
patients come to expert cardiologist, so here, if we do not have a monoclonal protein, they go for
PYP scan, and that's what makes them a diagnosis of other types of amyloidosis like ATTR. But some
times, if they have a monoclonal gammopathy, we do recommend the tissue diagnosis, and the tissue
diagnosis is important. And the question come up where they are. I mean, if they are in the
community or they are in a larger academic centers, sometimes we do cardiac, I mean,
endomyocardial biopsy. At Cleveland Clinic, we prefer that endomyocardial biopsy because we can
get answers pretty quickly. But in the communities, sometimes it's better to do bone marrow and
fat-fed biopsies. But again, we have to keep this in mind that the delays can happen. These
diagnoses can be negative. So the surrogate tissue biopsy is preferred if you have an access to that,
and you can done quickly. But the target organ biopsy, it's something is preferred if your
center has an expertise available, especially for the heart cases. But this is not the same
for renal disease. If you look at it, if I'm a patient, and I'm seeing the hematologist talk to
me that he needs to biopsy, and he's thinking about heart biopsies versus kidney, I might agree
on the kidney biopsy, not the heart biopsy. So we have to take this into the consideration. All the
heart biopsies has a less rates of complications than the renal biopsies. But from the patient
perspective, it's very different. So you can look at it this way that how the test accuracies are
there. And we all know the target organ biopsies are really effective. But we have to be very
careful that who needs a biopsy, who don't. Again, the multi-organ biopsies we discussed,
so similar way we do. Let me just pull this thing. So this is the algorithm I just want to
show you in my last slide. If you suspect that, if you have a high level of suspicion based on
an echocardiogram, we proceed with a biopsy. But if the echo is equivocal or unable to give you an
answer, we go for endomyocardial biopsy. And a similar way for other specialties, we can help
them if monoclonal gammopathies is negative, we can proceed with the PYP or SPECT scan, and that
will help to diagnose them. With that, a couple of key points here. So always try to use all three
serum immunofixation, urine and light chain assays. And echo-wise, we discussed that. And
then, you know, all these patients, PYP scan is something that we consider in those cases where
monoclonal gammopathies are negative, but echo is concerning for amyloidosis. Fat pet and bone
marrow biopsies, it's still the gold standard. There's no question about that. But center
expertise also.
So matters where these patients are and where their comfort levels are. With that, I'm going to end my
presentation. Thank you so much.